major twist tonight in the story
involving that leaked video of ABC News
anchor amy robach talking about the net
where she works for killing the Jeffrey
Epstein story now a TV producer recently
left ABC News for CBS has been fired huh
a short time ago she spoke with and with
News anchor megyn kelly Fox News chief
breaking news correspondent Tracy
Gallagher is helping to put the pieces
of this fairly complicated and
interesting story together tonight
tracing it Tucker the former ABC News
producer accused of leaking the amy
robach recording is 25 year old Ashley
Bianca when her former bosses at ABC
identified Bianco executives at her new
employer CBS immediately fired her but
during an exclusive interview with our
former colleague megyn kelly
Bianco says she is not the leaker watch
was it yeah I you know I'm not the
whistleblower I'm sorry to a PC but the
leakers still inside you know it's not I
never did any of that I may have
accessed it but I never never leaked it
I never showed it to anyone I didn't
talk about the situation outside the
company
Bianca acknowledges that as part of her
job she recorded Amy robots rant about
how ABC executives buried her explosive
report about child rapist Jeffrey
Epstein hears part of that watch she was
in hiding for 12 years we convinced her
to come out we convinced her to talk to
us
it was unbelievable what we had Clinton
we had everything I for three years to
get it on to no avail and now it's all
coming out and it's like these new
relevance and I'm freaking had on all of
it I was so pissed right now actually
Bianca says she told her manager what
robot said but that pretty much everyone
in the office had already heard it but
Bianca says she never heard of Project
Veritas until they released that tape
and she never spoke with Project Veritas
founder James O'Keefe and O'Keefe today
confirmed that in fact late today
project Veritas published a letter from
the ABC insider who they say leaked the
tape that person writes to ABC News
quoting here I like many are at loss for
words on how this has been handled
instead of addressing this head-on like
the company has in the past it has been
spun into a mission of seek and destroy
innocent people that have absolutely
nothing to do with this are being hunted
down as if it were all a sport and
Ashley Bianco just wants her career back
look how many days had you been at CBS
four days you know yeah you bagged I
pleaded I didn't know what I had done
wrong and I just you know I didn't I
wasn't even given the professional
courtesy to defend myself you know I
didn't know what I'd been accused of it
was you know humiliating I was
devastated we reached out to both ABC
News and CBS News for comment so far no
response
Tucker remarkable story trace Gallagher
thanks so much for that yep